eine traurige nachricht an diesem
heutigen tage für alle berliner weil
jeder berliner kennt udo walz und
darüber hinaus was wissen wir über seine
letzten tage seine letzten stunden ja
moritz das ist leider alles wirklich
sehr dramatisch muss man sagen dann udo
walz lidia an diabetes das war auch
bekannt
nun hat er so vor rund zweieinhalb
wochen so hat es seinen man uns erzählt
eine art diabetes schock erlitten musste
aufgrund dieses diabetes schocks dann in
ein koma versetzt werden
und der ist wohl aus diesem koma so dann
halt nicht mehr aufgewacht zumindest ja
und ist heute mittag um 12 uhr friedlich
eingeschlafen so sagt sein mann und das
natürlich eine traurige nachricht für
nicht nur alle seine mitarbeiter die er
hatte für seinen mann mit dem man ja
sehr viele jahre zusammen war sondern
natürlich auch für alle seine freunde
und darunter natürlich sind natürlich
auch viele viele prominente
na klar es ist der promi friseur
schlechthin gewesen für für deutschland
über also für mich der erste wirkliche
promifriseur danach kam dann nur noch
auch noch promi friseurin er war einfach
der promi-friseur und was wir wissen ist
er lag im krankenhaus
tatsächlich kam da auch nicht mehr raus
wie war das jetzt so kroner zeiten mit
dem besuch durch sein ehemann war das
möglich das war leider nicht möglich
dass es natürlich auch tragisch denn
sein mann hatte kontakt zu einer corona
infizierten person wodurch er sich in
quarantäne begeben musste und dadurch
konnte seinen mann carsten nicht ins
krankenhaus und udo besuchen musste sich
halt in quarantäne begeben und konnte in
den letzten stunden seines mannes nicht
mehr an seiner seite sein mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dir hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren